التباين في اعداد القتلى الروس بين كيف و
موسكو لا يقلل من حجم الحدث القوات
الاوكرانيه تقول انها قتلت وجرحت المئات
في الضربه التي وجهتها اواخر قانون الاول
ديسمبر الماضي للمعسكر الذي يتضمن مستودعا
للذخيره في مدينه مكيفكا الواقعه شرق
دنياك التي تحتلها القوات الروسيه الاخيره
نشرت اعداد المغيره لكنها تقر بتكبد خساره
فادحه في يوم واحد
صواريخ حربيه جديده الانفجار على مركز
الانتشار مؤقت قتل 63 جنديا روسيا الاعلان
عن هذه الخسائر اثار على الفور انتقادات
لقياده العسكريه
التي يتهممها زعيم الانفصلي السابق بتخزين
ذخائر في مبنى غير محمي اتجاه الغرب
ولليوم الثالث على التوالي تستهدفه موسكو
هذه الضاحيه شمال افريقيا
في المنطقه وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه تم
اعتراض اكثر من 20 طائره مسيره كانت متجهه
نحو كاف لو اصابت اهدافها لا تسببت في
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي والماء عن
المدينه باكملها على غرار ما حصل في
العديد من مدن البلاد